If you want to talk about a story that is
pure evil, I mean, just pure, unmitigated
immorality.
It is this breaking story from Vanity Fair
that Donald Trump's son in law, Jared Kushner,
abandoned or decided never to build the national
corona virus testing program because of the
political calculation that the Corona virus
seemed to be hitting blue states and not red
states.
And their plan was djent.
Jared Kushner's infinite wisdom was, let's
just allow it to run its course and in blue
states and we'll blame Democratic governors.
This is according to just a blockbuster new
report in Vanity Fair.
As always, with the Trump administration,
it's not just immorality.
It's also incompetence, because as we now
know, the 20 top hot spots in the country
other than California are all in red states.
So not only was it immorality, it was also
a miscalculation that this thing wasn't going
to spread to red states.
Now, understand, people died because Jared
Kushner said the virus is in blue.
States will blame Democratic governors.
We don't have to really build a testing program.
We wondered early on.
Well, when you first of all, really early
on, we wondered why Jared Kushner even had
a role in the government.
But OK, I mean, early on in Corona virus,
we wondered, why aren't we building a testing
program January 20th, roughly within hours
of each other?
The United States and South Korea got our
respective first cases.
They immediately built a testing program as
well as a tracing program, as well as fever
clinics to isolate people.
And South Korea had one of the best responses
to Corona virus in the world while still ranking
higher than the United States on the democracy
index.
It was not some thought, wild authoritarian
response in the United States.
Meanwhile, we didn't develop testing cases
started to climb confused messaging.
We don't want the WHL test were developing
our own test, but our test development failed.
Meanwhile, South Korea had already essentially
gotten 90 percent of the control of the virus
done and we still didn't have testing.
And the rest is history.
And we're about to have 160000 people dead
as a result of this virus.
Eventually, the Trump administration started
claiming we did have testing.
We have the most tests in the world.
We have the best tests in the world.
All of those lies which we know to be lies.
But there's still this kind of question mark
of what happened in the middle.
Was it merely Trump saying, let's not do anything
because I don't believe this is going to become
a big deal?
Was there a calculation of some kind?
And Vanity Fair's report is very specific.
The Kushner team, which had been put shockingly,
I mean, that the fact that there was a Kushner
team running, this is a major insanity.
But the Kushner team decided, let's not do
a national testing program.
Let's start with this is in blue states.
This is the job of governors.
And then we will say this is the fault of
Democratic governors.
Look at how great these Republican governors
did.
Now, why did they do it?
Well, if you looked at the map in early April.
The virus was mostly in blue states.
Right.
The early hot spots were the New York City
area, including New Jersey, California.
Boston was an early hotspot, Chicago, Illinois.
And of course, the early hotspots were the
places with a whole bunch of direct flights
to China and to Europe, the early places that
were sort of the sources of infection for
the world.
So their idea was their gamble was they thought
it's going to stay in blue states.
This is going to be a blue state problem.
It was dumb to think that, of course, if you
understand virology at all, but that's not
Kushner's area of expertize.
And so they said, let's just let it run.
Let's not develop a testing program.
It'll be great politics because we'll be able
to say, look at the failures of these blue
state governors vote Republican in November.
Now, it's backfired in two ways.
It's backfired politically.
It's backfired from the point of view of health,
which is, of course, the real tragedy.
So first, politically, it didn't stay in the
blue states.
And in fact, this has been the major issue
that has destroyed Donald Trump's approval.
In addition to the economy, which relates
to the virus and Trump's handling of race
issues, those are the big three.
But the virus is the biggest on which you
see a large gap between how do you believe
Trump handled it and how do you believe Biden
would have or will handle it.
So it backfired politically.
But more importantly, because I care about
people in terms of health, not developing
a national testing program early led to way
more cases and way more deaths, period.
Now, there's a lot of people continuing to
tweet stuff like Trump's not responsible for
one hundred and sixty thousand deaths.
Of course not.
Who's saying that?
The point is, there are plenty of.
Deaths which are extra unnecessary deaths
due to the federal government's handling.
Just look at just about any other country.
Very few countries have done worse than us
in terms of response.
And so that Delta, the delta between this
is a global pandemic and some people were
going to die.
And the number of deaths we have, which is
now 160.
One estimate says it could be 300000 by the
end of the year.
I mean, it's bad.
We're getting up to fifteen hundred deaths
a day again.
Some of that is attributable to I guess now
we've learned it's Jared Kushner to blame
for the non testing decision.
Now, a more important question is, what is
the number of people that Jared Kushner's
protocol led to no longer be alive?
And I want to be really clear.
Right.
Like, they decided to let it rip.
They decided to let people die because it
was a political calculation.
They miscalculated it.
They thought it's going to kill people in
blue states and then we'll blame Democratic
governors.
That didn't work out.
So that's a dystopian, dystopian nightmare.
But it's actually even worse than that because,
you know, we there's that phrase Hanlon's
razor.
It's an aphorism never attribute to malice,
that which is adequately explained by stupidity.
Earlier, we thought that what was going on
was just stupidity or primarily stupidity.
We are now learning that it was malice.
This is actual malice.
The allegation made in the Vanity Fair article
is just let blue staters die.
They could have done testing, but they chose
not to.
Shouldn't someone go to prison for this?
People are asking about, oh, you know, should
Kushner resign?
Resign.
He should be in prison.
And by the way, he was never elected.
He was never confirmed.
He is certainly unqualified to even be in
this position.
And he made the decision to allow people to
die for a miscalculated political gain.
Now, we've talked about like a little kid.
Trump deserves a consequence for what he's
done.
The consequence is being voted out in November
because nothing else is going to happen.
Jared Kushner is also up on that list of deserving
a consequence.
But I really want to be clear here.
This also is on Trump.
One of the maybe misguided reactions to what
we've learned about Jared Kushner here is
Kushner is solely to blame.
Trump picked Kushner.
And to some degree, the buck stops with Trump.
Right?
I mean, Trump, all of Obama's presidency was
tweeting time after time after time.
The buck stops with Obama.
So the buck has to stop with Trump here as
well.
I hope people are are understanding that.
So this is another scandal that in the midst
of a dozen others is getting one percent of
the attention that it deserves.
What happened to Russian bounties, Moderna?
What happened to the new health care plan
that Donald Trump claimed was going to be
signed into law yesterday?
There's nothing, I guess it's every single
day and it has to stop.
And this is I mean, this is now a type of
evil that goes far beyond incompetence.
And I subscribe to Hanlon's razor.
Much of what we've seen during the Trump administration
has not actually been malice.
It's been indifference.
It's been maybe negligence, but it's been
led by incompetence.
This is now a very specific allegation of
not incompetence, but actual malice.
And they must suffer.
The consequences were never getting back the
people that died as a result of Jared saying
it's mostly in blue states.
Let's let
it rip instead of developing testing.